cuando era Crianza solution kind of
non-compliance
ab c--'s determinism even that Vince
here
Desmond amends manifestation to change
the coding or accreta
I start walking that we too must resume
to waste cambium
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the UEFA Champions League the
pinnacle of club football were the
world's best clubs compete and icons of
the game like Gerard and Cruyff cemented
their legacies the world's biggest
league joins the world's game and a
special thanks to the legendary Hans
Zimmer and la zone Vince staples for
collaborating with us on the trailer and
I really love the trailer because it
captures our epic vision for how the
Champions League comes to life in FIFA
19 and Lina's gonna tell you a little
bit more about that as Aaron said the
UEFA Champions League is an amazing
addition for the game it's where
football's biggest heroes like Ronaldo
and Neymar
clash every year and it's the place
where champions rise and you've been
asking for this for a long time and we
are thrilled that it's here and that's
why we're bringing the Champions League
across the game will be an authentic
Champions League tournament mode your
club will chase this trophy in career
mode Alex hunter will pursue Champions
League glory in your story mode the
journey and in FIFA Ultimate Team will
be live and authentic Champions League
content and we'll share more details on
that along with all our other Ultimate
Team features later this summer and all
that's just the beginning as you know
the heart and soul of FIFA is gameplay
and this year we're giving you the tools
to control the pitch in every moment
from your tactical approach to the match
to each technical touch and we know how
passionate you are about gameplay so
we've worked hard to shape and refine
our vision for FIFA 19 with input from
our community from hands-on tests with
beginners to detailed feedback sessions
with FIFA pros and we're gonna be
sharing a lot more about gameplay
throughout the summer but what I can
tell you right now is that the quality
barring gameplay was raised yet again
this year so we look forward to
everybody experiencing the game on the
hands-on sessions this week and also of
course we're extremely excited for
everybody to play it when we launch on
September 28th and that's our FIFA 19
news
headlined by the UEFA Champions League
but I just wanted to take a minute to
pause and reflect standing next to this
trophy is a little bit surreal you know
growing up there's two iconic trophies
that every young player dreams of
winning and for your club it's this one
the pursuit of Champions League glory
but for your country it's this trophy
the World Cup and with the tournament
starting in just five days we're excited
for the world to compete for it in FIFA
18 as you can imagine all of us on the
FIFA team can't wait for the start of
the World Cup and we want to celebrate
with FIFA 18 players which is why we've
just updated the game with a free World
Cup experience on PlayStation 4 Xbox one
ps3 and Nintendo switch but you can take
Ronaldo and Portugal to their first
World Cup victory or you can write your
own story with some great nations who
didn't qualify this year or you can make
a crazy dream a reality for your home
country like mine Iceland who would have
thought that the nation of only 350,000
people would ever qualify and you can
feel their excitement
apologies to any England fans in the
room that might still stain and Lina
isn't the only one who's excited
FIFA 18 players are loving the World Cup
experience so far but we don't want to
stop there we want to invite everyone to
come and join the celebration so I'm
pleased to announce that for a limited
time FIFA 18 complete with the entire
World Cup experience is available for a
free trial on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
and on PC through Origen access yeah you
can download and play the entire game
right now for free
so to kick off the trial we've got some
of the world's biggest creators we're
gonna be playing live at the end of the
show representing their Nations in a
little mini World Cup tournament and
this summer will bring so much more for
FIFA fans plenty of FIFA 18 content
centered around World Cup and we'll
bring you all the details on FIFA 19 but
in the meantime let's all enjoy the
World Cup thank you and he's done
[Applause]
[Applause]